hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 19 video
another big age of Ultron crossover
there's also some news floating around
ABC TV because they cancelled revenge
so Emily VanCamp is now free to do more
Marvel stuff if she wants or go
somewhere else I'll try to explain that
even though there was the big crossover
this week on agents of shield the price
still includes some reference to age of
Ultron in next week's episode too but
this is probably the biggest crossover
this week that we're gonna get just
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet starting with
top five moments number five Raina's
gift is starting to become a bit of a
problem inside the Inhumans the problem
is is that Rena might start using it to
try and create some influence inside
their community create a cult-like
following and try to influence their
behavior she got Skye's to go rescue
Lincoln and even though she wasn't lying
about her vision her mother felt like
she was manipulating Skye
I don't think Raina was overtly trying
to manipulate her it's not like Raina
has a thing with Lincoln or anything
like she she wants him back just as bad
as anyone else I think it's more to the
idea that Raina feels like her gift
gives her great power over other people
again like she's regaining some of the
status that she felt before before her
physical transformation there was that
Skye sonic the hedghog joke I thought
your special power was collecting gold
rings that was kind of mean I think
things between rain and sky are gonna
get worse before they get better but
there was a reason Skye's mom said that
all decisions based on your gift need to
go through me now there's no way that
rain is not gonna misuse that gift for
now I'm just I'm not thinking of her as
a villain she's kind of an antagonist
not really though because she is
informing them on where the sceptre is
like she sees the events of age of
Ultron I see an army of Metal Men
destroying everything the answer number
for Coulson and Gonzales both play each
other just a little bit close and makes
a bargain with Gonzales to get into the
Hydra base in exchange for Fury's
toolbox if you were confused as to why
he was so willing to give him the
toolbox at the end I definitely think
that Fury is coming back to get it at
some point whether or not he actually
comes back on the show you know we have
no idea there are some things they
mentioned in this episode that I feel
are still kind of spoilery to talk about
if you haven't seen age of Ultron yet so
next week we can address them a little
bit better but I don't think Coulson
would have given him the toolbox if
Gonzales was going to be able to hold it
for a long time
Gonzalez's interest in the toolbox is
purely as it relates to powered people
he wanted to get a couple on the base
now he's done that the next logical step
would be to start tracking down other
powered people like the Inhumans in the
afterlife place even though technically
he's not a sinister character he
probably wants to find them just as bad
as Hydra does Hydra is the one that
wants to experiment on them moving at
number three bringing the old team back
together this is a lot of fun like the
season one team gets back together on
the bus the old team in the old place I
like the way during the briefing scene
where Ward starts to just go on and on
and on
Coulson finally says no more talking
from you at all
Fitzsimmons Skye may are all like yeah
we wish we would have shot you in the
face the whole subplot with Simmons in
the episode was awesome I loved seeing
her go super dark if you were wondering
whether or not Bakshi was you know was
really brainwashed or if he was just
pretending it's a moot point now because
he got vaporized and does anyone else
think that because of that final
confrontation between Ward and Simmons
where he's like I'm disappointed in you
where he just kind of throws it in her
face
do you think that that's gonna drive her
to do something even darker there's only
a couple places the character would
logically go from that one they get
super pissed and try something even
crazier or they would start hating
themselves for failing Simmons failed
her promise that's what she meant when
she said I made you a promise that she
would kill him since I don't see Brett
Dalton leaving the show anytime soon
that they're just gonna leave that
hanging in the air I did really like
Skye's fight scene it seemed like they
shot it in a single take like the camera
just kept moving around her there
weren't any cuts in it you know
logically if this were a movie you would
see her using her powers more it just
you know they didn't want to waste too
much of the budget but I was kind of
hoping to see from her is using her
abilities to enhance like punches and
kicks logically as her abilities evolved
she'll be able to fine-tune her
movements like that right now it's more
like a blunt force instrument moving
that's number two ward plants agent 33
inside shield they didn't have that big
scene at the end where he was explaining
to Coulson I thought that I could help
her I can't I'm not a good enough man
for that raise your hand if you think he
was lying through his teeth she is in
there for a reason there's only a couple
episodes left so we're not gonna have to
wait too long to find out what it is
they could be after information they
could be after the toolbox they could be
after something else
and finally my number one WTF moment age
of Ultron crossover
Marie Hills cameo in the idea of the
scepter theta protocol calling the
Avengers in that's probably as close as
we'll get to an age of Ultron crossover
they said that an Avenger would be
coming on agents of shield Maria Hills
an Avenger so I don't think that we'll
see any of the a-list Avengers but it's
totally possible that one of them could
come on agents of shield before the
finale so it turns out the Coulson's
real reason for infiltrating the Hydra
base dr. lists base was to find out
where the scepter is he gave the
information to Maria hill who then
related to the Avengers so in the
timeline of events this episode takes
place before the opening scene of age of
Ultron just in case you haven't seen the
movie I'm not gonna talk about how that
figures into the movie just go see it
this week you'll totally understand
sokovia scepter Baron von Strucker seda
protocol is just the mission to call the
Avengers in to go get the scepter that's
what Coulson meant when he said time to
bring in the Avengers he wasn't talking
about shield he was talking about age of
Ultron he's talking about the movie dr.
lists also did mention the the test
subjects in sokovia he was talking about
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch he was
like I hope that more people survive the
treatment and he was talking about death
Locke and Lincoln and their cells
actually did look like Quicksilver and
Scarlet witches cells in Winter Soldier
as if like the Hydra bases were almost
identical but here's my big question for
you guys you know how did you feel about
the age of Ultron crossover were you
hoping to see an a-list Avenger or do
you think that they're still gonna do
that before the end of the season I'm a
big Cobie Smulders fan I'm totally down
for them using more Maria Hill in the TV
show and in the movies the problem is
with movies like say Captain America
Civil War is that they're already so
bloated with big a-list actors this is
just not quite as much room for these
secondary characters like Maria Hill
Sharon Carter is a good example of that
too so I said they cancelled revenge
so Emily VanCamp is now free to come on
the TV shows be in any of the movie she
wants what's most likely gonna happen is
is she'll probably just join another ABC
TV series she was the lead actress on an
ABC series on a major primetime series
so I don't see her stepping down her
role and being a supporting character on
a show that's already got way too many
characters think about Mockingbird on
agents of shield Adrianne Palicki pretty
big actress not seen on screen a whole
lot if they brought Emily VanCamp
on agents of shield then they'd have to
feature her even less Bobby and her
are supposed to be leading the spin-off
series so if we do see Sharon Carter she
might show up on the spin-off series
again more than likely Emily VanCamp
will just like have a small cameo in
Captain America Civil War and then join
another ABC series that has nothing to
do with superheroes or marvel
there's nothing contractually preventing
her from say going on like a like a DC
TV series like she worked with greg
berlanti a lot in the past and greg
berlanti is like mr. DC TV right now
he's got Supergirl he's got the arrow
verse just to explain the the legal
situation behind the scenes so when a
Marvel film actor signs a contract it's
only for the Marvel films there's no
option for them to appear on the TV
series because they get paid like a
fraction of what they get paid to appear
in the films it's the opposite for the
TV actors the TV actors contracts are
way more restrictive the standard Marvel
TV contract does have an option for
actors to appear in the films but they
don't get a lot of extra money so it's
not like they're gonna get rich from
appearing in the films Marvel isn't
noted for overpaying actors the only
exception is Robert Downey jr. so if an
actor like Emily VanCamp
is still capable of leading her own TV
series and there isn't like a Marvel TV
series that demands her as a lead it's
to her benefit to not sign a contract
her characters actually a big part of
Marvel's Civil War comic book but if
they do end up using her in the film
it'll probably be in a similar way to
what they did in Winter Soldier just as
a support character which is kind of a
bummer I know it gets really confusing
when you start talking about the way
Marvel treats its TV actors and it's
film actors Joss Whedon actually did say
some really interesting stuff about Phil
Coulson inside the Avengers universe
inside the film's so what he said is is
that he feels like Coulson is still dead
inside the movie universe even though
everything's connected he said that he
was kind of disappointed because of
Coulson's still alive then it takes
weight away from that death moment in
the first Avengers film if he can't kill
anyone and you know that no one is gonna
die then there are no stakes he said
that that was a big problem at age of
Ultron like raising the stakes but
knowing that he wouldn't be able to kill
certain people if you have seen the film
please use spoiler tags if you're gonna
talk about character non deaths
character deaths etc for those that are
asking yes I will do a spoilery review
of age of Ultron as soon as the movie
comes out that's a I'll propose
like on Thursday or something like that
if you haven't seen it yet I did do a
non-spoilery review you can click here
to watch it it's a great film make sure
you go see it you can also click here
for all my other agents of shield videos
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you